so you said finding money for CEO G was
what a three year it was probably about
three years I had an idealism that I
write the script and it be a David
Sedaris thing the first and probably
only put David Sedaris project and my
thing was so okay even though it's all
dark an offbeat
people are gonna want to make it you
know people are gonna make this and make
it on a higher end indie budget level
you know like a few million and it was
night it was a little naive on my end to
think that you know I was putting a lot
of restrictions on it you know I think
when you're going for money you need to
know what how willing how where are your
priorities for me my priority wasn't
controlling the material keeping the
script the same and being able to decide
on having you know the final say on
casting like those are the kind of
things that are gonna push investors
away it's not to say that have embraced
all those things anyone were to jumped
on board ultimately I'm making a movie
that was dealing with religious things
theme sexuality you know stuff that
isn't necessarily every time I see him
an independent film I'm like I don't
know how they got it financed and I mean
I always feel it as a compliment you
know especially gonna see ones made like
been like how did that happen I think
every single film finds its own way and
usually that way is totally different
than the previous way you know I mean
this this was it was just a long process
of really getting a lot of knows at one
point I think I calculated it was like
it's sorry once it got like over like a
hundred fifty nose or so I just I
stopped counting like I kept a running
chart and when it was like hit that many
of people like financed ears or
producers or companies production
companies that passed on it then I just
like stopped keeping a number tally
because I got a little depressing you
know I feel like I have a thick skin but
I think it's okay for anyone to feel
like 150 rejections on the same script
is a little it convene at all
mind-numbing you know but um it was you
know but it was about
I thought the system would sort of serve
me a little better like I thought well
I've made my first film and people saw
it and people liked it and now I've
written the script and it's a well-known
author and I have agents and it's gonna
it'll it'll come together and the way it
should and it was kind of wrong for me
to feel that way because ultimately it
came together through whatever resources
I sort of engaged and build and so I had
support
from you know film independent that I
had on my own that I had built over over
the years and they I got brought into a
program where I met a producer who came
on board the broth financing you know so
some of those things ended up being
through my own path and not say it as
anything negative towards the agency
route but just to say that like at no
point should you ever just sort of be
like okay well now I have reps and
they're gonna get it all taken care of
like you know at the end of the day
you're only with you're always
responsible for yourself and I think
financing is no different just about
always staying on top of anyone you know
anyone who might know someone with money
and just always staying persistent on it
and keep on pushing and keep on pushing
because it's it's gonna everyone's gonna
say no I mean rarely do it I think I've
really ever heard of a story where
someone was like I was really accept the
script out people liked it we got a babe
like it that maybe happens with genre
films but I don't think it ever happens
with a drama or comedy or especially not
a dark comedy no
you